can you please explain to me who is deep
panda well apparently it's a one of
another of many Chinese cyber espionage
units but this one has been in the last
year a couple years been doing some some
really interesting things hacking into
health care providers pharmacies the
kinds of things kinds of places where
they can get a lot of information about
individuals but it turns out that their
their main goal isn't actually that
information their main goal may be to
steal defense and military secrets from
the US and what they seem to be doing is
building giant databases on individuals
in key places like defense contractors
in government and you know there's
probably no better place to look for
some of that stuff than in your health
records so this may be just a giant
Espionage game where they're looking for
information they can use to either get
into people's computers who are in
sensitive places or in fact even that
step further which is just old-fashioned
human espionage and trying blackmail or
use the information for otherwise Mike
you've always been so good at explaining
the mechanics of how these hacks work
was this hack so far as we know a
particularly sophisticated one or did
anthem just not protect itself very well
well anthem has gone out of its way and
and some of its contractors have gone
out of their way to say that this was a
very sophisticated hack and the one
thing we do know about this intrusion
group is that they are quite
sophisticated and what you know that can
mean lots of things one of the things
that that seems to be coming out though
is that the way that anthem stored all
of this data you can increasingly the
the the state of the art is to take data
that's that's resting sitting in servers
and keep it encrypted especially data
like Social Security numbers anthem
didn't do this and they're saying that
one of the reasons they didn't do this
is it makes it very hard or at least
harder to use you have to unencrypted
encrypted back and forth they wanted a
database that was much easier to use but
that means that was also much easier to
steal that may be the case but I'm sure
a lot of Americans are waking up this
morning to the knowledge that their
social security numbers weren't
encrypted and are very concerned and
trying to figure out exactly what is
going on like what can you tell us about
how far along the investigation is so it
looks like this started before this
latest incident anthem how far have US
investigators gotten so in the
particular anthem case they they seem to
discover the data leaving their network
last Thursday so we're still in really
really early days they called the FBI
and they and they brought in an expert
consultant group almost immediately they
seem to believe that they stopped the
attack before it got much worse there
are indications that that 80 million
number may come down a little bit as
they get as they learn more but but they
could also learn that the hackers had
been in much longer they could learn
that they had access to different kinds
of data it's like that we are early days
in this there's another investigation
going on which is US intelligence
officials are very concerned about
Chinese cyber espionage cyber spies
taking health data not just from anthem
but from all over networks all over the
country and there's a larger US
intelligence investigation about what is
going on how are they using this data
what it's what is it for do they have to
really be worried about about ken
account or about espionage efforts using
this data at down the road Mike for the
last couple years federal officials have
been frustrated that companies take so
long to share news of these breaches it
makes their it makes their jobs more
difficult to coordinate a response where
are we right now in getting companies to
be more upfront about what's happened to
them well the anthem seems to be a
really unhappy that they were breached
and and that anger has translated into a
you know more aggressive and affirmative
action they call the FBI right away by
all accounts I think you know after Sony
you're seeing more and more companies
were just pissed off and who are a
little bit more willing to step up now
in anthems case because they lost social
security numbers and a whole lot of
other stuff there were US regulatory
requirements that they report this but
they do seem to have tried to get in
front of this as quickly as they can
might believe were there but actually
just a very quick question do we have
any idea did we name them deep panda or
do they call themselves deep panda that
means running really band that
d fan is is the name given to it by a
security company called CrowdStrike it's
got other names by given by it by other
companies but but that's just the most
evocative one defendant